Justin you have this is a fine cast but  you have the coolest deepest register  and of course you're playing my guy and  I'm the bad guy  yeah and that must have been fun to  channel the bad guy all I have to is my  voice to be the bad guy I have to it is  fun to channel the bad guy and some of  my favorite Lego not bad guys but voices  like Will Arnett Will Arnett famously  when he was great as Batman and then  you've seen his truck commercials where  he's also the voice and then he also  he's very proud of those votes horseman  yeah I I kind of looked like a  hodgepodge of those three things and and  put it into Garmadon to try and fill  that very big throat of Will Arnett yes  yes what you're trying to fill the big  throat of Will Arnett yeah same how  should I encourage just want to fill  Will Arnett's throat this will not be  misinterpreted or turn into a meme don't  worry about it  you